Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update the Wii U received a huge sales
boost over the weekend all thanks to
mario kart 8 UK retail tracking company
gfk chart-track said sales of the Wii U
in the UK were increased by six hundred
and sixty-six percent specific sales
figures were not divulged but the firm
added that eighty-two percent of total
mario kart 8 sales in the UK came
through the bundle Mario Kart 8 was the
second best selling game of the week
only behind Ubisoft's watchdogs notably
watchdogs launch 45 platforms while
mario kart 8 is a wii u exclusive watch
dogs is the fastest selling game in
Ubisoft history and has also crushed the
record for first week UK sales for a new
IP with unit sales fifty-eight percent
higher than the past record holder LA
noir Nintendo has not announced the
official mario kart 8 sales yet next
week the NPD group is expected to
disclose US industry sales for May but
because Mario Kart 8 was released on May
thirtieth it will only count two days of
sales so if you just got your Wii U
through a mario kart 8 bundle stay tuned
to GameSpot's coverage of e3 next week
and see what else you can put on that
fancy new system of yours